I turned the phone lines right now and
and have a guy who without just throw
out there he's a friend he also happens
to be the general manager of the Los
Angeles Rams he goes back to the st.
Louis Rams days and he's the one that
just pulled the trigger on a big trade
involving two first-round picks for
Jalen Ramsay he is the Rams general
manager less neat how are you les I'm
good it's good to be on with friends and
yeah what I can't promise I will not be
as fun as Steven Naismith a bit you know
what it's a bit blast it's just you know
it's just who Steven is and it's who you
are but I can enjoy you're both just the
same less you know what I'm saying you
know what that's that's that's true
versatility there all right let's get
into this right away les how long were
you in on on jail and ramsey was it from
the first second where it appeared that
there might be some sort of disharmony
there in in Jacksonville I think when
you anytime a an opportunity you know
trades you know trade opportunities are
unexpected but when they do crop up it's
up to probably any organization to do
their due diligence their analysis to
determine if that opportunity is worth
seizing for them at that moment so we
always do that due diligence and
probably 9 times out of 10 or that you
know nothing comes about but we did
begin some of that when when the I guess
you when maybe there was a little bit of
smoke that he may or would like to be
traded and when it all came down to it
les I mean you of anybody knows the
value of what it means to receive
multiple first round selections that's
how in essentially you began building
what you've built here now in Los
Angeles back in st. Louis when you
traded away the pick that the Redskins
used for rg3 how hard you have to
swallow before call for enough to
first-rounders well it you know it's
always you definitely have to analyze it
and assess is that the best thing is
that the best thing for the Rams right
now now I similar like you brought up
saying Louis I think what you
to assess it is where are you
let's call it in the time line or are
you building are you close to breaking
through have you just broken through are
you contending and if you are how do you
continue to continuously contend and and
you know what you did have to assess is
kind of predict where you might be
drafting in the next couple drafts and
simply put what we did the way we look
at it and let's call it simple algebra
terms is alright our two twenty first
round pick is Javon Ramsey and it really
doesn't matter where we're picking if we
knew we could pick a player that was
going to live up to you know that type
of projection and and be a known
commodity we do it in a heartbeat and
and but because he was a known commodity
and is a really good player and at the
top of his game right now
it basically cost us another player in
the 2021 draft so did you get a chance
to chat with Jalen before you said okay
to the trade no we didn't we didn't get
a chance we chat with him until after
the trade probably could have if we
would let's call it a stew but we had
done our due diligence but a lot of
Jacksonville Jaguars you know in our
building who've basically been teammates
with him so yeah I guess we got to cheat
a little bit there but and and obviously
any time any players in the draft you do
a lot of due diligence on them when
they're coming out because you never
know even if you don't get a chance to
draft them one day when an opportunity a
project that you can actually acquire
that player and any concerns about his
back less when you acquired him well I
think what we did know is is we were
going to have to do due diligence there
and and that was one of the first things
we did when he when he arrived was go
get the physical and that's that's
definitely part of the term sheet it
would basically all trades is you know
the player has to arrive get a physical
pass that clubs physical to basically
consummate the tree and it's it's just
interesting to all of us in the media
lest that the the back seems to be just
fine when he arrived in Los Angeles well
if you want to get technical with it
right he has had you know three to four
weeks till so a lot of injuries are
three to four week type injuries Los
Angeles also has healing powers in
itself less you know that having been
here for the weather meditation right
you know you can eat right and so you
haven't had any conversations at all we
all know he wants to get paid and he
wants to get paid a lot and that has
been apparently part of why he wanted
exit visas out of Jacksonville what is
your current position on that subject
Leslie what we mean one of the things we
also did right before we completed a
trade was which was get a chance to chat
with with his representatives in and and
we basically presented our paradigm and
and he presented theirs and and we
definitely agreed to continue moving
forward with the trade so Jalen was
jacked and were jacked and we're looking
forward to building relationship with
him and and anytime you do a situation
like this you're definitely you're
definitely not doing it for the
short-term you you you bring you bring
Jhelum in with long term expectations
well right now but you obviously know
the way the leverage game works I mean
you just coughed up all this all this
draft capital for him you can't afford
to let him walk so do you have an
essentially maybe a parameter of a kind
of what but we definitely didn't talk
numbers on that and we basically just
say this is this is kind of a you know a
time on our paradigm and and I think
what we always do as a as an
organization from a telescopic view
right
there's probably certain positions that
you probably plan on you know taking up
it's called a significant amount of cap
space one of those positions is corner
if you have the right corner so as you
as we look into the future we're always
thinking right
it's you know he pina players who can
score touchdowns players who can pass
the football players who can block you
know the blindside rush the passer cover
cover players who can you know school
touchdowns I think you always are
playing in the future you might have to
or be prepared to budget for that
particular player at that particular
position if they're the right player and
certainly if that player can cover
somebody say let me just pluck a name
out of the arrow let's say say Julio
Jones this very Sunday what do you think
do you think Ramsey's out there this
weekend that that definitely helps what
now this is what's interesting what
we're dealing with is because he has not
practiced for you know three to four
weeks and I did do some things you know
last week he hasn't really gotten his
body that I call it the fifth gear in a
while and it takes five gears or getting
that body to the fifth gear to play in
this league so we have to assess him
today on the Flex field we have to be
mindful of the travel from from one
coast you know the east coast to the
west coast yesterday traveling back to
Atlanta then getting on playing on
Thursday you know after Atlanta game and
going to London so these two weeks are
going to be demanding on his body based
on miles traveled time zones changed and
what you know as he was rehabbing in
Jacksonville and not necessarily getting
up to fifth gear so we're gonna we're
gonna let the sports scientists getting
home it was a wise assessment and and
but I can tell you what the coaches want
to do that's why I was about to say I
didn't know you refer to Wade Phillips
as a sports scientist less I didn't know
that that that's his new nickname I had
no idea well you wait wait wait personal
you know you
Porter account does son of bum he
certainly does woulda never thought that
uh Popovich with the sports
either so I think coach Popovich has
proven that you know what wisdom prevail
right here yeah before I let you go less
the body that everyone's been talking
about obviously for for quite some time
involving the Rams has been Todd Gurley
what is his status is you and I are
talking right now
well his today's uh today is very
important in our practice routine and
when I say that it's the day where we do
try to and again this is where sports
scientists come in and improve football
we do try to get our players to fifth
gear today for certain amount of reps
and I think this is this will be a very
good day to assess where Todd's Claud is
and we're all hoping that he's that he
you know passes the test this afternoon
but that still do be determined okay and
in terms of his knee last I mean it just
seems right for him and I understand you
know I've had coach McVeigh here and
I've had so many people here saying
there's there's nothing with his knee
it's just the way of the circumstances
of a game and then sometimes we'll have
a terrific game like say against the Box
a couple of weeks ago
is there a lingering issue involving his
need that has concern for you less I we
we're you know I think the the only
thing is you know me when you're running
back you take a lot of pounding over the
years so I think over the years and he's
traveling mean I think since he's been
drafted coming in this year he's
traveled more yards than any human being
it's cool more touchdowns than any human
being and I think you when you've seen
us in the red zone this year that there
I know there's three I can think about
maybe four where you know he got the
ball he had a crease and and he maybe
met some defenders trying to keep him
out of that end zone and I think those
are the type of runs that that show that
hey Todd's got you know plenty left in
the tank and are you is there a
different plan for him this year because
sometimes the bell cow that we have come
to know in those years we traveled all
those yards is not shown up on the field
well I you know what the song says and
so them determines how it goes but I
know Strong came into this year knowing
we
that three quality running backs and I
do think there is a there is an element
of awareness but there's no there's no
Excel spreadsheet that says that
anywhere in the building that I've had a
lot of touches over you know since he's
gotten the league and you probably
common sense sports signs and said you
know what it's probably not getting the
same amount of touches over you know
these next four to five years and how do
you best manage that but again there's
no spreadsheet it's how the flow of the
game goes and it's also hey where's
Malcolm Brown at how is he one because
they're different styles of running and
against certain defenses the different
genres that you know it's kind of like
you know myself and Steven a Steven a
Fitz
and we definitely love to get Darryl
Henderson involved we you know we
drafted him with intent and and he
showed some explosion last week and I
think we'll continue to see him get
experience on the field last one for you
less from your position where you
watching the games and obviously a
general manager once the the game starts
you're kind of just a spectator like
everybody else your thoughts on the
officiating and the way that past
interference has been officiated on the
field and through replay for the first
six weeks is it what you expected
well III always defend the officials on
the field because when you go down there
even even where you watch from I watch
up a little bit higher the games a lot
slower seems a lot clearer than when
you're right down on the field I mean
the angles and the geometry is different
and it's just a fast game so I do think
they do a really good job I think my
take will be after assessing it is
they're basically only they're probably
saying you know what if it's egregious
we will turn it over but we've you know
it would seem to me they're saying okay
we're not going to allow this to be
let's call it more tactical than
preventing something
Regis but that's my take from 30,000
feet but serious those guys on the field
have
a lot harder job than us you know
watching either you know FOX NBC CBS
ESPN you know hit really really slow
motion and high death sure no I I'm with
you you know obviously it's easier for
us to when we're watching it on a
television screen but I guess when you
have conversations with McVeigh I mean
it seems to me that coaches are less
likely to try and challenge anything
anymore
because they feel it just needs to be
something to the level of pure almost
robbery in order for it to be upheld or
challenged or changed or even a flag
being put down on the field has has your
conversations with with Coach gone in
that direction we think you have to and
there's probably some other penalties
too you know so you know that are going
that you have to adjust and and you're
seeing a little more blocks in the back
called when Lyman are pulling on the
periphery there so each year you
definitely had to adjust and what you're
gonna and that's different than then I
know Shawn flowing a flag but my point
being maybe it's just blocking
techniques based on based on the trend
and where and how the calls are being
called but I do think if if we and we
were a part of it right in New Orleans
if the reason we allowed pass
interference whether it's offensive or
defensive to be replayed I think it was
would be an intent that if something was
so egregious you wouldn't let it affect
the outcome of the game and it does seem
like we're probably trying to keep it
from being just a tactical type you know
challenging less I'm so glad my sports
scientist said Stephen a is best for our
one and less is best for our two I think
it's worked out perfectly thank you yeah
you know what it really has we share the
same sports scientists best best to your
better half less okay definitely she's
definitely my better half take care of
yourself
we both we both married up that's less
need Rams general manager for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app